Francis Collins former head of the
NIH testified in a closed door session
with the house Corona virus subcommittee
admitting that the co lab leak theory
was credible this marks a significant
shift from the earlier Char
characterization of it as a very
destructive conspiracy okay also accused
both doctors of using their influence to
pressure researchers into favoring a na
natural origin Theory over the lab
Theory regarding CO's origin Dr
Collins's testimony addressed his role
in the publication of the March 2020
proximal Origins papers which played a
key role in shaping The Narrative about
CO's origin now